three months ago training for a local
championship today twelve-year-old
archie battersby is fighting on an
international stage his mother's legal
battle to keep him alive now a matter
for the united nations my boy's really
not in a good place at the moment it's
just
it's unnecessary the hospital are fully
in control of this situation
you know and i think that
if they do
go ahead to do that after they've all
they've they know that the un are now
involved i don't think it's going to
look very good for this country at all
weeks into his hospital treatment the
nhs trust taking care of him took her to
court
here's what happened first the high
court ruled that the hospital could
carry out a brain stem test in order to
determine whether archie had died but
when the clinical team realized the test
wouldn't give accurate results the high
court judge relied on mri scans to rule
that archie is most likely dead the
family challenged this at the court of
appeal arguing that you can't declare
someone dead based on a balance of
probabilities and so it went back to the
high court to determine what would be in
arch's best interest
last week the high court ruled that
archie's prognosis is so bleak that it's
best to withdraw treatment the court of
appeal upheld this decision
the supreme court supported it by
refusing to intervene it led the family
to the u.n britain is a signatory of the
united nations convention on the rights
of persons with disabilities or the
uncrpd which means that it should abide
by the decisions of the un committee and
if it doesn't then it's breaking
international law
experts say that the un has never before
brought a case like this against the uk
but five years ago the committee
criticized britain's approach when it
comes to withdrawing treatment from
disabled people the un treated body does
not have
any enforcement mechanism
and it will issue a view or an opinion
that it would expect the uk to comply
with even if there is no binding
authority to enforce
a decision or an opinion
it reflects very badly on that state
when it doesn't bart's health nhs trust
says it cannot delay withdrawing
treatment without an order from the uk
courts in a statement it said we're
giving archie's loved ones time to come
to terms with the decision of the courts
that treatment should not continue and
are involving them in each stage the uk
government told sky news it has received
the un's letter and will consider it
carefully and respond in due course
sadia chowdhury sky news in london